so what does this talk about so there's
a lot of common misconceptions about
programming languages you know
something's better than something else
and other things are obviously just so
outdated we should never use them ever
again
there's also ideas that parts of the
tech community or better than other
parts to that community or have rules
that don't make sense
there's also this idea that you know
open-source is so much better than the
enterprise or enterprise is so much
better than the open-source for reasons
so we're going to try to work on these
legends and see if we can do away with
some of the myths if you saw the talk
title what this talk is not about is
actual urban legends so if you came here
looking to learn about the Loch Ness
monster or the chupacabra that's not
going to happen and I apologize I'll
give you a moment to walk out cool I
just broke my clicker again so let's
start with Ruby how many of you do Ruby
or have done Ruby Ruby's like my people
I love Ruby I was a Microsoft developer
for years and then discovered Ruby
because I had to and of course I was
asked can you learn Ruby in a weekend
and I said no I have a family that's not
realistic but I did learn Ruby and I'm
so glad that I did it's so much fun
Ruby's great you know it's designed for
programmer happiness right but it gets
this this thing this stigmatism and why
because rails if you're not a programmer
or you work with someone who's not a
programmer like say your boss they often
think that because you're using rails
and the big the big catch phrase is
rails is magic you can get 90% of the
work done in ten percent of the time
they think you just everything's really
easy the other side of rails is it has a
very vocal person who created it who has
lots of opinions about lots of stuff and
one on one he's a great person on
Twitter not so much but it kind of gets
this attitude that all rubyists are just
like DHH they're opinionated they're
hipsters they don't care but the thing
is Ruby is not Rails that's myth number
one you could do a lot of Ruby without
ever using rails I've developed a bunch
of applications that have nothing to do
with rails there's so many other
frameworks out there you can get Ruby to
the web without ever using rails you can
use Honami
or Sinatra or anything there's lots of
different options so
do away with the idea that the rails
community is the Ruby community it's
just a part of the Ruby community the
other day is that Ruby is not useful I
want you to take this in for a second
read this comic this is a personal
favorite of mine
so the assumption here is that the
slightly chubby guy wearing the Ruby
t-shirt wearing a hat has a beard making
useless apps that no one's ever going to
use this is the average rubyist now I am
slightly chubby I am wearing a hat I do
have a beard but that's not me and not
representative of all rubyists by any
stretch of the imagination now granted
yeah people do make useless apps in any
language not just Ruby but this whole
you know I built an espresso something
that finds single source espresso and
Soma because everyone of course who uses
Ruby works at a start-up in San
Francisco that makes equally useful
products and the other guys like cool
I've made the app that keeps this plane
in the air good for you hopefully it's
not United had had to slip that in there
but yeah I mean like this is kind of the
concept you know I even saw this as I
was getting ready for this talk as I was
coming here this is a tweet that came
out like the night before I got to to
Denver and I was like come on and names
have been redacted to protect the
innocents but I was like seriously it's
2017
be realistic Ruby is strong there are
large scale large scale companies using
Ruby logs IO we use Ruby Zendesk uses
Ruby how many of you Zendesk it's pretty
common ticketing system Hulu blue box
you know Twitter still on the back end
uses Ruby these are huge companies so to
say that Ruby is for hobbyists or Ruby
is for hipsters is just unrealistic so
let's talk about Ruby's mortal enemy of
course as PHP how many of you have been
or are PHP developers don't be
embarrassed put your hands up so the
first of all let's do away with that
myth that rubyists and PHP people don't
get to don't get along there's some kind
of cross Berens and and yes maybe at one
point in the beginning there there was
because whatever politics and reasons
but PHP is an amazing language I mean a
lot of hands went up and I said who's
done PHP because PHP does a lot it
powers like 80% of the Internet
so when people come up and say PHP is
dead man that thing is it's gone 80% of
the servers on the Internet are running
PHP in some way shape or form
even within rails there is a PHP tie-in
so that you can port PHP code to Rails
and use it effectively so if it's dead
I'm pretty sure 80% of the internet
wouldn't be using it
what are some other myths about PHP
there's no objects in PHP and if the
last time you use PHP was like PHP 4.3
you're probably right
it wasn't it was just basically
jazzed-up home pages it said for
personal home pages when it first
started out so that's realistic if
you've used it since then you know 5.0
to 7 we won't talk about PHP 6 because
that's a whole other issue that I don't
have time for it's all object-oriented
they're focused on the object is it
functional programming no but that's
again a whole other talk so it is
object-oriented is not realistic to say
it's not PHP is slow um this is a
perspective issue I mentioned Ruby
before everybody says Ruby's so PHP is
slow these things are so and as
developers our concept of slow is
totally skewed we're like wow that took
point zero zero four milliseconds that's
taking way too long
someone's looking at your web
application chances are they don't even
notice that it was point zero zero four
milliseconds they just know that this
page came up when we're talking about
users using an application that's when
we worry about slow and that number is
four seconds and if your code is running
at four seconds you have deeper deeper
problems than the particular language
you're using to develop so slowness is
is an entire entire myth what else PHP
is is not secure this is another issue I
know there's a lot of stack ops folks
and folks in the crowd and I think they
all understand that if you're not
developing with an eye towards security
you've already screwed up who cares what
language you're using you need to have a
secure application when you're
developing it regardless of the language
you're using so PHP is just as secure as
Ruby or Java or Python or anything else
so let's put that myth to bed security
is on the person building the
application it's not on the language
they're using Java
who doesn't love Java Java also
considered
you okay maybe I shouldn't have raised
my hand my bad
Java is is is another ubiquitous
language I mean people yeah hands went
up because Java is also a very
cantankerous to code language it's
difficult it is not easy but at the same
time it does do amazingly powerful
things how many times you see this thing
pop up because you downloaded you know a
DocuSign and your job is not up to date
in order to sign the thing so you can
get the new job or fill out your
healthcare benefits or anything like
that
if Java wasn't working properly it
wouldn't be working for you
Java has to be built and it's a huge
huge thing and and grande it doesn't
have a big loud community like Ruby or
PHP but it's still out there
people are still proud to be making
great apps and logs io we actually use a
lot of Java on the backend Python when
Python came out it was very much an
academic scientific language you know pi
math and pi Sai and and all these
different pieces and you'd never use it
to build a web application or do
anything you know fun like building
single serve espresso apps for anything
South of Market in San Francisco why
would you use Python for that it's a
scientific language it's built for
analytics that's what Python is all
about but Python can be a lot of fun
I mean tell two stories here this was
the keynote last year from railsconf
which was one of the entire like six
talks that I went to at railsconf
because you just go to railsconf to hang
out and talk to people but this was a
presentation by one of the gentlemen
from Spotify and he was demonstrating
some of the cool things that they're
building at Spotify using Python and one
of them this was my favorite thing was
called boiling frogs and the way it
works is is you name one artist and
another artist and it will find ten
things in between them to to link them
up so he used I believe it was who's
that girl who sang the comi maybe song
Carly Rae Jepsen Carly Rae Jepsen - Amon
Amarth which is a Viking death metal
band from Sweden and I was like there's
just no way I don't care how good your
algorithm is you can't bring this
together and he did in ten songs
absolutely amazing I suggest you go
watch the talk it's it's really cool
another thing that that I did at one
point in time used
work for a pass and we were very big in
supporting the open source community and
there used to be this really cool thing
called get tip and yes there was
controversy to get tip I'm not going to
get into that that's not that's not my
talk but we wanted to give back so what
we did was we wrote some Python scripts
that would list a bunch of people that
we wanted to give money to on a weekly
basis and we put the money and it took
it from her bank account and in to get
tips so they could get some recognition
for what they were doing which is really
cool and that's not academic that's not
scientific that's just love that's just
having fun with the scripts you can
write and the applications you can build
so obviously you can do a lot more with
Python than just scientific boring stuff
Linux not a programming language but
hear me out here
I mean this is 2017 is the year the
Linux ducks desktop right I have the
year correct okay I wanted to make sure
I may have given this talk before in
different years and made the same joke
but Linux is is one of those things
where people are like Oh Linux will
never be mainstream it's for neck beards
and their basement building scripts you
know living with their parents hoping
for enough money to pay for their cat
food and cat litter
you know it'll never be a mainstream
thing that is one of the most
preposterous things I've ever heard and
I've literally had people say it's for
neckbeards don't don't bother with Linux
focus on you know mac OS or that other
thing with the windows don't worry about
Linux it's never gonna happen but how
many people have taken a flight where
there's movies involved and then the
movie thing went down and then you see
this penguin guy because almost every
major airline is running Linux at least
for their entertainment section and for
the please buckle your seatbelt because
if you don't know how to do that by now
I don't know why they need a video for
that so Linux still a major player in
every market pearl pearl is awesome how
many people have done pearl yeah wow
that's a lot of hands so I added this
slide because a little while ago I did a
blog post called Ruby is dead because I
had gone to 20 Ruby conferences in one
year and almost everyone had a panel or
a talk or an open discussion about
Ruby's dead long live Ruby blah blah
blah so I I did this and for some reason
Aristotle picked it up and was like well
his pearl dead
just more dead than Ruby and it's like
no pearl is not dead they just came out
with a new version and it's amazing I
haven't done anything major with it just
played around with it but compared to
pearl you know even five years ago it's
light years ahead and yes it took a long
time to develop and but Larry gave us
gifts he said I want to do this right
and he did so far from being dead pearl
is still a major player swift Swift is
the future I'm done thank you you have a
good night
when Swift came out it was of course the
newest bestest thing that was going to
allow you to build mobile apps with the
small caveat that it was an open source
and you had to pay for it and people
have this attitude that this is the
end-all be-all we could solve all
application problems with Swift and then
I saw this tweet and and it's a bit
dated but I love this tweet because it
opened up so many questions in my mind
objective-c developers are now obsolete
please treat them with respect so okay
we're gonna put that statement aside for
a second we're gonna ignore those
brackets and focus on the other things
that are apparently obsolete old people
are obsolete what I'm pretty sure that's
most of our goals is to get to the point
where we have to ride the bus with a
cane because that means we've succeeded
in life to live that long but this is my
favorite part
pregnant women are obsolete what like
this is the best you could come up with
is our pregnant women I'm I'm not a
biologist but I'm relatively sure that
for the success of the species the human
species we're going to need more
pregnant women until the science catches
up and cloning and all that jazz they're
not obsolete and you know - my mom
wasn't absolutely when she was either
luckily Swift did open source stuff they
got a little they calmed down a bit
they opened things up they made it a
little better so it's it's now a viable
option and not complete utter [ __ ]
anything with the jas how many people
have coated anything with a Jas every
hand should go up if you've ever coated
anything ever and this is great a couple
years ago there's just like this burst
of Jace's you know we got things like
dough's j/s which super useful I'm sure
you all know what that's used for
cracking j/s you know all of these kind
of things that were just like okay and
and I don't mean to make fun of the
JavaScript community there's nobody's
fantastic it's amazing there's so many
things you can do with it and you know
angular is really cool and ember is
really cool like these are really cool
things have been thought out but for a
little while there was just Jay s all
over the place and you got to be like
does anyone know what cracking Jay s
does not a hand goes up because none of
you work at PayPal because it was
developed by PayPal it's a JavaScript
payment gateway there's no way you'd
know that by the fact that it's called
crack and jas but there's so many more
languages out there and this is the main
point of this myth a lot of people think
they need to focus on one thing become
the master of one thing and make it
great and it's not really about the
tools that we use as developers we solve
problems so if we're solving problems
for our clients our customers they don't
care what what we're typing into the
command line what text editor we're
using they don't care that your vim
versus Emacs they don't care about any
of that [ __ ] they care that you've
solved their problem they care that you
know they were able to order you know
800 Amazon echos in 10 minutes for
whatever reason that's what they care
about problem solving it's not about
being with it it's now about grabbing
the coolest new thing and saying you
know now I'm a go developer because
that's cool it's about really focusing
on what solves the problem it's also
about evolution as a person there's more
to you than being a developer but as a
developer there's more to you than being
a specific type of developer there's
more to you than just DevOps or there's
more into you than just being assisted
man there's more than just being a
designer you have to grow in that space
so let's talk a little bit about my
favorite than communities so in a lot of
ways like DevOps days is kind of a
community unto itself and that's really
cool I really appreciate that about not
just DevOps days Rockies but all the
DevOps day's events but if you look at
this diagram this was like the perfect
demonstration of what I'm talking about
so if you want the red the folks in red
up in front that's the Ruby community
and the folks in blue that's the PHP
community and you have the Java
community all the other communities and
they're all kind of together linked by
that line that is the technology but at
the same time they're all separate and
that's a problem
part of that problem comes from the
things people say their impressions and
I'm going to read these because these
are literally things and then no
attributions I will not say who said
these things but these are things that
people say that are absolutely
preposterous to me designers aren't
developers they shouldn't be at hardcore
tech meetups I don't know about you I
can code things backwards and forwards I
can make things work they function they
do what they're supposed to do and
they're in Times New Roman with a white
background in black text because they
look like [ __ ] I can't design anything I
can't design anything at all and then a
designer comes along and makes magic and
now everything's beautiful so to say
that designers aren't hardcore or
they're not techie enough preposterous
one of my favorite CICIG mins can live
without developers what do we need them
for ok that's a very interesting concept
there was a little bit of friction on
that this was someone that I worked with
and I just kind of leaned over and I
said ok so let's say all the developers
go away cool
what are you assistant min for what's
going on the server just gonna have a
server sitting there that you're
monitoring and taking care of
preposterous this one a little bit weird
business folks don't get developers
business folks that make the upper
effort absolutely do they should be a
part of the tech community if they're
selling tech or they're hiring for tech
or they're running a tech company they
have to be involved and if they're
involved they will they will understand
developers and in a little way as a
developer it's our job to help them get
their tech people are socially inept all
of them I've been doing this for a while
I've considered myself a fairly social
person I may have played a little beer
pong with giant oil barrels last night I
think that's a pretty social activity
talk to a bunch of people so that's just
complete and utter [ __ ] it's about
cross-pollination learning from other
groups if you don't accept everyone then
you're not going to get everyone's
perspective and if you don't have
everyone's perspective it's just like
coding something without ever showing it
to a user it's like building something
without ever having someone use it that
means you have no idea how it's going to
be used and you don't really know what's
going on
so cross-pollinate this way we can make
a better tech community we can make the
tech community awesome so let's talk a
little bit about open source in the
enterprise apple and oranges right I did
work for a year at IBM as one of their
teams as a advocate for open source that
it was an interesting experience they
have a lot more loopholes to jump
through but I learned a lot will go back
to this the idea that one person's code
is better than another person's code
obviously the guy in the in the collared
shirt and button-down is is an
enterprise developer and the other guys
a ruby guy so he works with open source
and of course all open source people are
dirty scumbags who live in their parents
basement feeding cats you know I think I
already cover the whole neckbeard issue
and of course all business people are
like ah business they work in dirty
little gate great cubicles to build
software for other people who work in
other little dirty grey cubicles but
that's not the case there's a lot we can
learn here you know if we get along and
we understand the open source developer
can teach the enterprise developer a
little bit about creativity a little bit
about craft and how having the input to
do things allows you to actually move
and have some artistry within your code
and the enterprise developer can teach
open-source developers a little bit
about organization and how to have
things you know running in a certain way
so that you're better serving the people
who are part of your community so
there's something to learn what else
there's this idea out there and I know
if you've ever been on LinkedIn or any
job board or anywhere on the internet
ever that involves being hired there's
this concept of the rock star wizard
ninja how many of you are rock star
wizard ninjas put your hands down
fewer rock star you would be up here
there would be a band playing someone
would be singing people would be going
nuts it'd be amazing to be making a lot
more money than you're making right now
if you're a ninja maybe you are but you
couldn't have raised your hands because
I'm not able to see you and as much as I
love Harry Potter wizards aren't real
probably so this whole idea that you
know we're special because we're
developers or were special because we're
a certain type of developer or we do
some special function within the tech
community it's a myth it's garbage and
we need to stop feeding that so when you
see the job article or you get that I
saw your github profile and I wanted to
send you an email you're a rock star
ninja wizard if you see that just
respond with no I'm not
find some other do
the idea is that if we're cool with each
other if we're nice to each other we can
build a better tech community and that's
really what it's about a better tech
community means better code better
applications better things built for our
companies and ourselves and better
people being better to each other that's
really what it's all about you know open
your herbs give people hugs unless
they're tactile defensive then don't
give them a hug you'll get punched in
the face
thank you very much
[Applause]